all right we're back yeah this is
ridiculous
i know we got to replace that laptop i
guess yeah maybe i should actually
i mean i don't really i can't really
afford to get a good one but
that never happens you know you can
never afford it you know just happen
it's just something that has to happen
yeah because this one i
i bought this one specifically for
streaming and it's just like it's not
cutting it
cutting it maybe there's something out
some way we can maybe upgrade it or
something yeah i gotta look into that
you know
um but yeah i was just i was saying when
i saw like the um
the comments first coming up i was like
mrs evans arty party that's a great
[ __ ]
that's a great handle yeah i just have
no idea why it works so well for
damn what nearly a year yeah
and then all of a sudden it decided i
don't know
it's weird i don't know i think we've
had that for about a year
i don't even need it not even that much
no i don't even think it's been that
long about six months huh i don't think
it's been that long
really okay i mean and like i said some
people have said because like i said i
just kind of got i went to target
and uh just got kind of whatever they
had which wasn't a lot
we tried to buy something else but it
was out of stock yeah yeah yeah
so i ended up getting this one and a lot
of people have told me that this one
it's hewlett-packard so a lot of people
have said ah yeah sucky [ __ ]
yeah i wish i could afford like a really
nice mac laptop but
i don't have [ __ ] fifteen hundred
dollars to throw around
michael shafer says try reinstalling the
operating system i may actually try
doing that
i mean i got to do something i don't
know what the [ __ ] going on with this
um all right so you want to get back to
uh what we're talking about yeah we have
to
all right stay here for three days
i told it's not that bad come on okay i
mean some of this stuff
like some of the notes we don't have to
go into every single thing i'm just kind
of like skimming through the [ __ ]
um so as i mentioned before uh there
were rumors
kind of after the shooting happened that
uh
you know eric and dylan were in the
quote unquote trench coat mafia
uh that was not the case they literally
knew one person that was in it
um most of the people that were in the
trench coat mafia was just kind of like
a little joke
click that they put together like they
were shaking down
people for picking on bullies or so i
don't know what the [ __ ] they were doing
they wore black trench coats just
just to be funny i guess uh most of them
had actually graduated
by the time that the shooting happened
so as i said these two were not
in that so i kind of feel like there
that was another thing that got added
onto the narrative
so anytime you can even wear a black
[ __ ] trench coat after this [ __ ]
happened
everybody would think that that's what
it was so um
as i said they were both really into
computers and one of the things that
they did
that they and this was pretty high tech
for 1999
they linked their personal computers
together on a network and played doom
over the internet which not a lot of
people were doing in 1999 high-tech [ __ ]
i mean i was playing doom but i wasn't
playing i wasn't like i didn't have like
linked i was just kind of like playing
it i had the [ __ ] cd or whatever like
the disc i played it on there
um so inevitably after the shooting
happened doom got blamed
as well because it's a game where you
just go around shooting monsters
but you know how many zillions of people
have played doom over the years
i got to blame something they were
blaming [ __ ] records and [ __ ] before
this
yeah playing the music well they blamed
music on this
one
[Laughter]
it's just i don't know man it's really
cool priest got blamed for a [ __ ]
suicide yeah i remember that yeah just
stupid [ __ ] like
well as i said the the reasons for this
are always
complex just like the reasons for
everything are complex
humans really don't we really have a
problem with complexity
uh we want a very simple answer um
and there never is a simple answer so i
just kind of feel like it's very easy
for people to say like oh
doom made him do it or marilyn manson
made him do it and that's the end of it
i don't have to think about it anymore i
remember that judas priest case where
that [ __ ]
i think was called beyond the realms of
death or something it was an
old 70s [ __ ] song the jewish priests
wrote
and some kids gasped themselves to death
in a damn garage in the car
and uh for like a couple years
rob rob halford was just stressing
just stressing the [ __ ] out because he
had this court date to show up
where him and judas priest were gonna
have to face this
accusation of being involved in this
damn suicide
and he got there and he was they said
that he was a wreck
thinking about that [ __ ] thing i
don't blame him it's like i would be too
because i you know what how the hell did
i get this yeah
and he gets there i just wrote a [ __ ]
song man
he gets there and and they basically
like
throw the case out of court or withdraw
their [ __ ] case
and he's like that's it which that must
have been the most anti-climactic thing
he's been like stressing out for like a
year beforehand and then he shows up and
they're just like
don't worry about it what it's fine yeah
and he was just like
yeah i [ __ ] stress out about that see
this is why you shouldn't stress out too
much about stuff because
i don't think i don't make that is
exactly what the case was or something
they dropped the case against him or
or if they just went oh this is
unfounded you know it was some
some [ __ ] like that yeah they threw it
out pretty interesting instantly michael
shafer said remember when people were
killing each other because of dungeons
and dragons
yeah it's like i remember i still have
it back here somewhere oh yeah
um a book that came out i think it came
out in the early 90s and it was by that
crazy like exorcist dude bob larson
and uh it was all about there was all
kind of there was [ __ ] about like led
zeppelin and [ __ ] in there
there was [ __ ] about duns there was a
whole chapter about dungeon the dragon
so that was making all your kids satanic
and yay and whatever
grandparents are saying it's the most
ridiculous [ __ ] [ __ ] you ever it's
hilarious
grandparents will tell you that if you
play that [ __ ] you'll [ __ ] open a
portal and
demons will come through and [ __ ] like
that sure grandma
yeah and they say we should like respect
our elders [ __ ] that and so see this is
what
this is what we grew up with like i said
we lived through the satanic panic
so now it's just certain things but
other things that would be it was beyond
them
yeah anything that was involved in the
occult or
religions uh that was that was like kind
of like above their pay grade
they were very superstitious which to me
is
that's very very funny i mean just this
the whole concept
that you would actually believe that pla
if you do if you actually believe that
dungeons and dragons
or the like or listening to kiss or
something like that
would literally open a portal hell and a
demon would possess you
yeah you need therapy yeah i'm just
telling you that right now that [ __ ] is
not going to happen
it's fine it's just a game and it's just
a song
calm down yeah but it had dice
the bible says you shouldn't be [ __ ]
with that dice but uh
yeah and it's funny that gary gygax was
just like a [ __ ] nerdy dude living
out in california making up
yeah man thinking yeah man the dungeon
the dragon's game
just making a rope
people that are into horror movies are
generally
the nicest [ __ ] people you would
they're just dorky about it it's like
they love this kind of [ __ ] we like to
make this kind of [ __ ] up [ __ ] we
never do it yeah they look like they
look like [ __ ] dudes from the [ __ ]
ben jerry's or something yeah yeah it's
just
fun it's just fantasy it's not nobody
wants to do it i don't want to i don't
want to hurt anybody i don't want to go
on a mass killing spree or anything like
that it's ridiculous why would i do that
same kind of people that would maybe go
to like a [ __ ]
grateful dead concert and go into jams
jam out and drum circle and [ __ ] i mean
honestly i've been to like a lot of
horror conventions over the years most
horror fans are like the nicest [ __ ]
people in the world
and most goths are the nicest [ __ ]
people in the world yeah there's a few
that are [ __ ] but not
well it depends well yeah but i'm just
talking about in the sense that
they would like [ __ ] kill you you
know what i mean that's very very very
rare i kind of feel like the worst
people are ones that are like normal
looking because they can blend in
t i think that our first show may have
had something might have been the
satanic no she asked if we would review
the movie satanic
which i'm pretty sure we did i think we
did a matinee on that a little while i
liked that movie quite a bit i think it
was on shutter or
something or i remember watching it
maybe i rented it
i don't know but it wasn't too long ago
we did actually review that surface says
the only portal to hell kiss ever opened
with gene simmons zipper
that's exactly right you yeah i don't
want to think about his wiener
imagine that imagine that [ __ ] now
i'm going to talk about it
i'm going to see you think [ __ ]
florida's humid
open up that zipper there's nothing but
just like the [ __ ] steams of just
dangle bucks coming out of that [ __ ] in
his pants
his [ __ ] pants with [ __ ] those big
old platforms on [ __ ] spitting blood
[ __ ] that back in the 70s
crawling with crabs yeah i'm sure
among other things yeah
[ __ ] all them girls from long beach
yeah
well and from elsewhere yeah from but
yeah that was near
california they were i mean they go to
california they infest
all the [ __ ] of san diego with crabs
yep everyone everyone in san diego has
crabs now because of the cheese because
of jane 17 and the other dudes
you know what i mean peter chris
oh my god all right so where was i
so yeah so so these two two kids were
super in a doom like i said
me and my brother played doom you know
so
we didn't kill anybody just saying um
and actually eric harris like had
made had built like some of his own
levels for the game which i i guess you
can still access i don't know if you can
but there's
called the harris levels so these two
like online
they had nicknames one of them was reb
and one of them was
vodka reb was kind of uh you know the
columbine high school their
mascot or whatever's the rebels so i
guess he was uh talking about that
so um they had these websites
where they kind of talked about doom and
some other games they liked like quake
and stuff
but they also started writing these
kind of i don't know if you call them
like manifestos but they were writing
kind of blog posts on this website which
ostensibly was up there to talk about
doom and to
you know offer people their levels to
download but they were just kind of
talking about how they
hated everybody and um
you know we're building bombs and [ __ ]
like that so
they weren't like secretive about their
[ __ ] they started building pipe bombs
like way before
the you know the massacre and they would
actually show like they would take
pictures and they would talk about it on
their blog it's like hey we made this
pipe bomb and we blew this up and this
is
what happened and [ __ ] like that and um
you know they were just talking about
how much they hated everybody and wanted
to kill everybody so as i said this is
going back like
a few years it wasn't just like a spur
of the moment thing
they also uh had access to a lot of
fireworks because eric harris actually
worked at a fireworks
stand um and they started like kind of
sneaking out at night blowing [ __ ] up
whatever
um and this was started the kind of [ __ ]
where they were talking about hating
everybody and blowing everybody up that
started in early 1997 so a couple of
years
uh you know more than two years before
the actual
attack um he started talking about they
had the anarchist cookbooks they talked
about like all the [ __ ] about makeup
bombs and whatnot
so what ended up happening was that
um you know this was just a very
marginal website like you said in 1999
it wasn't you know a lot of people
weren't on the internet and especially a
lot of people
wouldn't have been looking on this
little like marginal site of some high
school kid talking about doom and
talking about how much
he'd like to blow people up um but in
august of 1997 apparently he had written
a blog
post that said
um that kind of ended with all i want to
do is kill and injure as many of you as
i can
especially a few people like brooks
brown
who was a classmate of his which i
i don't know what brooks brown did to
him it's weird because they made up
later
um i feel like what the the beef that
they had was like
super super minor but for whatever
reason it's like he wanted to kill
brooks brown i don't know why it's like
said it online
um and somebody that knew brooks brown
saw it
and reported it to um
the uh reported it to the authorities
okay
so because brooks brown's parents ended
up seeing it
so they actually reported it to the
sheriff's office in jefferson county
in early august of 1997. now
so they so they had an inspector so like
i said there were
red flags going on this these kids got
in trouble for [ __ ] like way before the
attack so i'm just saying that right now
um so this officer looks on their blog
and finds like a whole bunch of [ __ ] on
there where they're writing about hey
we're gonna kill this [ __ ] and
we're gonna kill that [ __ ] you
know what i mean so they had been making
like
you know bald face threats against
people
uh for several years prior to the attack
um
also there was you know he found all the
[ __ ] about bombs and whatnot
now but what ended up happening here
was that um i guess like the sheriff
like wrote an affidavit about it
and said oh also we found you know we
kind of looked through their [ __ ] and
found a pipe bomb
so maybe that's alarming and then like
the sheriff wrote an
affidavit about it but then like nothing
was really done about it like they
didn't turn it into a judge or anything
so it just kind of like
languished in a file somewhere and uh
you know nothing was done about it
because apparently nobody took it all
that's here
in january of 1998 eric harris and dylan
klebold
broke into a locked van and they stole a
bunch of computers and you know some
electronic equipment
now as they were driving away a cop
pulled them over
and um you know obviously they had all
the [ __ ] so
eric was kind of like yeah you caught me
we did it uh they both got charged with
mischief breaking and entering
trespassing and theft
now they got put in juvie for a little
while but they
actually were on their best behavior in
there um
so what ended up happening was that
while they're in there because they were
so
good uh they said the juvenile officer
said um hey we'll expunge your criminal
records
if you go to this if you do some
community service
and go to this like psychiatric
treatment program like which was like
really short it's like anger management
[ __ ] like that
so he said if you go to that then we'll
you know wipe your record clean
so they did that um eric harris i don't
think dylan had to go to anger
management but eric harris did because
like i said he had problems with like he
had a really volatile
temper um but he went there and nobody
thought anything about it they said he
seemed like a really nice normal kid
um but like i said he's kind of a
psychopath so he's good at
making people have the impression of him
that he wanted
uh he actually got out of the program
early for good behavior
um and sometimes these guys act real
well in
a structured environment that's true too
yeah
also they're under threat and they're
trying to get out of here yeah
you know they behave yeah and turn your
back on them then they do whatever they
want
yeah you know but i mean you do they are
able to behave
if they if they need to right but
you know obviously they kind of feel
like what are you talking about yeah so
so they got let out early um
some of the officers that you know kind
of watched over them
noted that eric was a very bright
individual who was likely to succeed in
life
and not so much um
and they also said well dylan was
intelligent but needs to understand that
hard work is part of fulfilling a dream
so i guess maybe they were kind of
calling him a slacker loki maybe
probably like a.d.d yeah
could be real you know impatient wants
it now doesn't really want
yeah they did say it was a little
squirrely probably they're talking uh
yeah
so they so what ended up happening so
eric harris had to write like a letter
of apology to the owner of the van for
breaking in and stealing all his [ __ ]
and he did that and he was kind of like
yeah sorry about all that
but like around around the same time
that he wrote this
letter to the owner of the van
apologizing he also wrote in his journal
and i quote listen to this [ __ ] you guys
isn't america supposed to be the land of
the free
how come if i'm free i can't deprive
some [ __ ] dumb [ __ ] from his
possessions
if he leaves them sitting in the front
seat of his [ __ ] van
in plain sight in the middle of [ __ ]
nowhere on a fry [ __ ] day night
natural selection [ __ ] should be shot
that's what he said the van was locked
so he so he apparently thought that he
was entitled to other people's [ __ ]
because they left it in plain sight in
their van
yeah that they left a very common common
attitude
well they knew this was the wrong part
of town you know what i mean
wasn't it it wasn't no yeah
other people yeah say well you know
i robbed these people you know they
should have known they're they're on the
wrong
you know this is a bad part of town you
know what i mean yeah
that happens here you know that's that's
that's the that's the uh
that's the rationale they should have
known better yeah i kind of feel
and this is why the kind of [ __ ] he him
writing [ __ ] like this in his journals
um because for me like reading like a
lot of [ __ ] that was in his journals
that really the attitude that he had he
definitely thought
that he was he had a god complex he
thought that
because he was smarter because he was
into cooler [ __ ] or whatever
then that gave him the right to do
whatever he wanted to anybody and they
were just stupid victims who he could
just
i mean he really had that mindset serial
rapists are exactly the same way
yeah that's what i mean he had like a
psychopathic mindset big time
you're like well she knew it was dark
out
you know she should have been walking
yeah she said with that vagina
like that in the dark yeah wearing that
like what do you think she is yeah with
that bra
i mean she should have known she should
have known that i was going to be out
there and it's going to be grabbing on
her you can't do that that's
that's not safe yeah and that's
yeah that's how they justify it yeah of
course it's everyone else's fault it's
never their fault
they call it victim blaming but what's i
i don't think that's a good description
what it is is they're trying to
normalize
their thinking they're trying to yeah
that's exactly what they're yeah
yeah yeah they're trying to justify to
themselves yeah or to the world
fifth yeah you know both she should have
known
yeah she shouldn't have been out there
you know well that's what
it if i didn't do it somebody else is
going to do it
that's what that's that's the thing yeah
you know
michael shaffer said one of these dudes
was depressed and suicidal the other was
sociopathic and homicidal
dylan would have probably been okay with
that eric see i kind of feel like that
too i'm not saying
you know dylan cleveland had a lot of
problems too but i think that if he
wasn't friends with eric harris i don't
think dylan would have done it alone
would eric have done it alone probably
um because i think that little [ __ ] was
a psycho
um also about a year before the massacre
dylan
wrote a message in eric's 1998 yearbook
which said
killing enemies blowing up stuff killing
cops
my wrath for january's incident will be
godlike
not to mention our revenge in the
commons which he's talking about the
cafeteria
so this was the kind of [ __ ] they were
writing to each other he's the edge lord
that oh yeah big time these these both
were big
time it's and this edge lording it just
it went really really really wrong you
know how everything's all grandiose this
is all really important
so well as i said that is a very common
psychopathic tendency they're very
grandiose very narcissistic
they they think of themselves as
god-like beings
yeah like with kind of special powers or
special abilities that happen where i'm
at
yeah yeah well like i said that's oh
that's why people can wait to see what i
do
in the comments yeah yeah yeah
oh they yeah it's like that's the center
of the earth like you're [ __ ] you
know
me like
meet me at the forum you know yeah yeah
it's it's shitty too because these two
you know in these journals they had
actually planned like much larger like
terrorist attacks
um they they were gonna do this attack
like i said the
the attack at the school was actually
planned to be
much much i mean as horrible as it was
it was actually planned to be much much
worse because they built
a [ __ ] ton of bombs yeah um propane
bombs
yeah and um had had those um
detonated uh body count would have been
maybe close to 500 just saying um
so like i said it's not good how it
turned out
but they were planning it to be much
much worse they were planning to blow up
the whole school and everyone in it
and had made like several plans uh to
that effect now it does seem like in
their initial planning that they weren't
really planning to kill themselves
because they had a plan to escape to a
foreign country afterwards
like yeah good luck with that maybe it'd
be easier in [ __ ] 1999.
um or interestingly they were going to
hijack an aircraft
at denver international airport and
crash it into new york city
and this was in 1999 before 9 11.
they're tripping well yeah obviously
because that's not what ended up
happening spoiler alert a lot of this
[ __ ] comes from them i've seen the
picture of the
boy's room i forgot which one it was it
was one that was making all the bombs
and it was kind of like a teenage
[ __ ]
kids [ __ ] paradise you know what i
mean he had all this [ __ ] video game
[ __ ]
[ __ ] music and posters and he had all
this
little bombs made and in boxes
and all this stuff to make stuff and he
had little guns and [ __ ] knives and
more than what you needed and it was
shitty stuff you know
they had a shitty little tech nine and a
shitty little [ __ ] high point carbine
and it's a shitty little [ __ ] pie
bombs you know
shitty ignition and [ __ ] it's just
the little [ __ ] propane bottles
what's funny is that i don't know where
they got this information i don't know
if they got this [ __ ] out of the
anarchist cookbook or whatever
yeah they did that's how they got it a
lot of that [ __ ] in there there's been
many additions to that stuff you know i
mean i don't know every
i haven't really kept it with each
edition but some in some of those
editions from what i remember seeing i
mean
the designs were just that's not the way
to go very dangerous
to do some of this well and very few of
them actually didn't
actually work yeah that's hard to do
with the [ __ ] propane
i'm not gonna sit here and give advice
on [ __ ] how to make field improvised
munitions uh yeah don't do that but
it to do that [ __ ] right you need proper
structured training you need to have a
very scientific background you're gonna
deal with chemistry
and if you make a wrong [ __ ] move and
and a wrong move is is bad okay
is you you will blow your [ __ ] up
you'll blow your [ __ ] up well bomb
making yeah any wrong move is bad all
right and a wrong move
might be buying the wrong kind of
thermometer
yeah that's the wrong kind of
thermometer might blow you the [ __ ] up
okay um just stupid [ __ ]
well this is what this is what we're
saying about the db cooper show where
the bomb that he had on the plane was
you know in all likelihood fake because
why would you make a real one what a
fake one works just as well
it's like don't try to you know why
would you want to risk blowing yourself
up when you could just
like tape some [ __ ] flares together
and be like yeah it's a bomb
[ __ ]
like you know what i mean they've had
dudes just do cardinal cardinal [ __ ]
sins
like build the trigger ignition
power source build it onto
the [ __ ] live bomb you just don't do
that
you got it hooked to the live bomb
you're building the [ __ ] you're
building the trigger and the [ __ ]
ignition system
on the bomb so what happens if you
[ __ ] cross a wire you blow yourself
up
you know that's that's how that don't
don't connect it to the bomb
you know it's just but that's how stupid
like i said don't give people ideas
well i would think even an idiot would
know that
you know well you would think an idiot
would know a lot of them a lot of them
blow themselves up [ __ ] just stupid
[ __ ]
well it would honestly don't tell them
anything because if they're stupid and
they blow themselves up yeah then there
you go
problem solved you know that's all i'm
saying um
yeah michael shafer was just pointing
out i might get into this a little bit
later but um
you'd be surprised how much gay fanfic
there is of these two online
still some very misguided kids out there
that idolize these 90s relics yeah
it's really really sad how much and like
i said a lot of school shootings that
happened subsequently a very
disturbingly large percentage of them
uh the perpetrators directly referenced
uh the columbine shooting as an
inspiration uh
which you know and like i said they're
still on reddit and stuff like that
there's big
fan bases for these two which welcome to
the internet it's simultaneously the
best place and the worst place
in the in the universe i mean
you know it's it's just it's terrifying
i don't understand it but yeah
uh so there were hey i'm uh i'm empty
okay you want to know yeah you're
probably empty too
so um you know they also kind of you
know made some uh videotapes very
famously they're
you know they made some they're called
the basement tapes um
where they had made i guess they made
like a
a video for school that was almost kind
of like
a practice for this it was called hitman
for hire
i guess they made it it was like a
commer like a fake commercial for a
class
where the assignment was you know make a
fake commercial for a business
so their whole thing was hitmen for hire
and they
actually he would not be allowed to do
this nowadays i'm pretty sure
but back then they were allowed to make
a fake commercial at the school where
they
wore black trench coats you know in
homage to the trench coat mafia
and went around the school with fake
guns like pretending to shoot people
you know because they'd been paid to
like take out bullies or whatever
um so yeah and it and they actually
from what i can remember i think they
got like a good grade on that because
they're like oh that's pretty
what it what a creative idea or
something like that like i said nowadays
if you did that
people like everybody be like yeah what
the [ __ ] the matter with you you
you'd have all kind of [ __ ] coming down
on your ass
um they also had so let's talk about
uh how they got all of the and like i
said
you know i don't want to go too much
into like all the technical specs of
like because that's kind of boring but
it's um
you know they made a [ __ ] ton that's as
scientific as i'm gonna get they made a
[ __ ] ton
of bombs pipe bombs propane bombs which
is like the big uh
you know 20 pound like propane tanks
that you can buy like the from blue
rhino or whatever you can buy in front
of every [ __ ]
7-eleven in america um and grocery store
they made a whole bunch of bombs out of
those um you know they had
a whole [ __ ] arsenal and like i said
this whole plan
initially was that they were going to
plant all the bombs in the school blow
the school up the guns
and they had a couple of knives as well
the guns were only for
essentially shooting stragglers that
that's what their plan was their plan
was they were going to blow up the
school and then if people got out and
escaped they were going to shoot them as
they were running out
obviously that's not how it ended up
thankfully um as i said it's
you know still horrible how many died
that day but it could have been
way way way worse because what they were
planning was way worse
now how they got the guns because they
were both uh minor so they were both too
young
uh they actually talked their friend
robin anderson who was a
couple of years older than them and i
one of them went to the prom with her
later on
she actually went to uh the tanner gun
show and she went
like the two boys went with her and she
was pretty much able to
buy the guns privately um thank you
for the kids even though they were
minors um
and she didn't really have to sign
anything or anything and that's kind of
why they went to that particular gun
show
because because you could get stuff
without you know anyone checking on you
even though all you had to do was show
you know that you were
over 18 which she could they couldn't
because they were both 17.
uh so she actually she didn't know what
they were gonna do obviously
um she did actually have to testify the
trial later on but they did not charge
her because
they couldn't find any evidence that she
knew what they were um
that they were going to do because they
actually ended up buying she bought them
um quite a while before the attack she
bought them in november of 1998 and the
attack wasn't until april 20th
um they also got you know when i said
earlier that they had a job at a pizza
place
um they also had a co-worker there named
philip duran and he
actually ended up buying some guns for
them as well because he was also
older um you know they were kind of
friends of theirs
now both of them did get charged because
some of the [ __ ] they bought was like
illegal because it was like sawed off
shotgun and whatnot um and like i said
they had made like a [ __ ] [ __ ] ton of
explosions just so
so many bombs um they made a bunch of
molotov cocktails as well
they had a bunch of um these things they
called crickets which are like carbon
dioxide cartridges filled with gunpowder
you know [ __ ] like that yeah it's mostly
[ __ ] yeah
i mean they made them they were very
homemade yeah which is why a lot of them
didn't work
they're very very ineffective i don't
think anybody was even harmed by any of
the ones the one
even the ones that even went off more
like glory no they weren't
glorified firecrackers and then the the
big ones the biggest one they had was a
it was a big old propane
yeah they they made a few of those yeah
they tried to set that up
no it didn't go off the only ones that
went off they made a few like
diversionary bombs like on the day of
the attack that were supposed to go off
like three miles away like
you know so firefighters and [ __ ] would
go there um those went off but not
uh to the extent that they thought that
they would
yeah well you can just go and look on
this mythbusters mythbusters just show
you what happens if you ignite something
like that
there's an explosion but it's not it's
not an effective
weaponized a fuel air bomb is very
difficult to make you got to release the
fuel
and then it has to be exploded and the
timing has to be perfect
and you need kind of what's called like
a remote detonation to it or
in other words the detonator has to be
away from the [ __ ]
expanding gases you can't get that down
by [ __ ] igniting it at the source
but that's what they were trying to do
it's just it doesn't work yeah and
well happily it didn't work um because
like i said it would have been like
[ __ ] way worse because the propane
bombs
that they planted have those going on
gone off um
it's very likely it would have killed
everyone in the cafeteria and
probably would have brought the library
which was on the second floor above the
cafeteria down
on them and probably killed everyone
they were talking no
okay they're talking if it went off the
normal way that's what i'm saying
it exploded at the source it wouldn't
have done that well there were more than
one though
it was still it's not enough yield what
they're talking about
is if it had gone off like a fuel air
bomb which is magnified many times
all right then maybe it would but
no you can't make a fuel air bomb out of
[ __ ] propane
they're they're they're they're blowing
that threat out of proportion
fuel real fuel air monitoring is
basically diesel fuel
especially you just have to atomize it
it's like blowing it through a
carburetor but you have to do that very
quickly
using low explosives and you set it off
with a [ __ ]
high explosive or something and boom
it'll go off it'll go off bigger than
any
you can make a fuel air bomb [ __ ]
make a destructive force
similar to a small atomic bomb but you
need a lot of it
it's the size of a [ __ ] 18-wheeled
truck you know that's how big it is
um yeah i'm getting out of the top
subject though
yeah what they made wouldn't have worked
couldn't work
no even if it went off it would have
yeah it would have done damage it
wouldn't kill everybody though
they're not strong enough if you've gone
off like a fuel air bomb like they
thought it would
it would it would but no that's that's a
complicated task to get that done they
didn't know what they were doing
yeah yeah michael shafer says these two
are partly responsible for every school
shooting subsequent
these two and the press generated grief
porn it's a form of social contagion it
is to a large extent and like i said
i that's why new zealand and maybe some
other countries i think they kind of did
the right thing by
you know reporting the perpetrators
names one time and then not ever
mentioning them ever again like so they
don't give people the notoriety and give
people the idea
like hey this is a good thing that you
should do like join in on this [ __ ] i
see
bury their names i i think they should
too bury their names and really only
allow it to be covered by the local news
don't bring take that or call them
something denigrating you know if you
ever have to refer to them
i would let it i would put the well you
don't want it to spread
you don't want the ideas for these are
kids they're dumb kids they don't want
to give it any attention
you don't want to name them you want to
keep it in the local news only
you know i think that's probably the
best idea i mean
because what you're doing if you put it
on the national stage that's that's just
like taking a cancer cell out of one
part of your body
and then injecting it all over your body
somewhere it will
it will stick well it happens it's weird
because it happens too
with uh suicide um
you know and this has been shown to be
absolutely
absolutely true uh if someone kills
themselves at a school there will be
like not a huge you know not everyone
will do it but they'll be like an uptick
yeah because you know yeah suddenly you
get the idea and the same thing happens
with mass shootings anytime that there's
i don't know what it is but there's
something about humans that
you know something horrific happens
we're really just kind of like drawn to
it and it's almost kind of like
there's a small percentage of people
that get the idea hey
maybe i'm gonna do that too you know
what i mean and i think it's like always
safer to kind of keep it
on the downwards it's bad because it's
like yeah people have a right to know
stuff but
i i just feel like they shouldn't blow
it up to this huge proportion where
everybody knows about it it was uh
although we're talking about it now
yeah it's the news business well we're
talking about it because
you know what it's the news business
eventually i think the new
news as a business will end up becoming
obsolete it's going to be real hard to
monetize that
when you live in a world of cell phones
and that will probably alleviate a lot
of it because yeah it'll happen people
will know about it but won't get any
traction
yeah because i think the problem is that
you know
a lot of times people know like what
human psychology is and they're like
look the more
horrific something is the more outraged
something causes
the more people are going to click on it
because people like to be outraged they
like to be
disgusted and horrified you know what
happened in a time when there was only
four or five television channels usually
and there was some
cable so and then a couple well i don't
know 99 that was kind of a lot of cable
in there yeah at that time you were kind
of forced
to [ __ ] watch what they wanted you to
see
that that is not the same as the
internet now that's not the same as
youtube
yeah and then all these other platforms
are coming up
eventually nothing will be able to get
attraction
which that will be a good thing probably
that's you do not want centralized
information control you do not want a
centralized economy
you don't really want a highly
centralized government you want
everything to be
local and customized and a network a
network is far more efficient
it's centralization is is old school
think about it yeah it's old school and
and this is a this is a what do you call
it it's a product of that centralized
information control
well in a way they got exactly what they
wanted i mean
one of the things that the shooters
wanted
was that they wanted to be famous they
wanted people to talk about them and
they said people still are
yeah and like and they spurred you know
a wave of copycats yep which they
probably would have been super happy
about because that's what they wanted
yeah and like i said they were riding on
that [ __ ] centralized information
system yeah i did it and i feel and and
so like i said because people said oh
this
you know this was not by any stretch of
the imagination first school shooting
uh it's just kind of like serial killers
you know within the 70s they didn't
appear in the 70s
it was all kind of serial killers going
back to [ __ ] victoria going back to
the [ __ ] ancient times
but it's just you didn't have you know
everybody
with access to information all the time
so you didn't hear about it
that's all it was um so
i i kind of feel like it proliferates
like the more people hear about it
because more people get the [ __ ] idea
if you don't [ __ ] hear about it then
maybe you don't think about it you know
yeah it's just kind of like
and uh you know it's kind of like a meme
not in the
not in the sense now of like a picture
with [ __ ] words on it but in the
original uh definition that richard
dawkins
coined back in the 70s where meme is
you know he he coined it to be like gene
because
it's like it's like something that
propagates itself
but it's an idea rather than a
biological
thing you know what i mean like
something that goes on to that so that's
that's what that's where the concept of
meme comes from in case you didn't know
it's kind of like a mind virus not a
literal thing but he's just saying that
it spreads
like a gene would spread uh and in some
of the same ways but it's not a physical
thing
so all right so let's talk about like
the timeline of the actual
shooting so you know this is pretty
horrifying but we're finally getting
into
because i feel like we've spent enough
time talking about these two [ __ ] so
let's kind of talk about
the victims and what actually like
happened on that day
so it's a tuesday morning april 20th
saying thank you zack
what was it with the evangelicals using
tragedies like this to push their morals
yeah i kind of want to get into that a
little bit because there was kind of
like a big
[ __ ] uh false narrative spun about
this which was kind of a shame
um and the fact is that even after they
were corrected they were just kind of
like [ __ ] it everybody already knows
that narrative so we're just gonna like
go with it because it's making us money
um you know yeah so i want to get it
a little bit too um yeah he said it
seemed like that happened all the time
in the 90s and 2000s
yeah you know they're they're just just
like everyone else man they're just like
on the grift
anything that's gonna make them money uh
they're gonna jump right on that [ __ ]
yeah michael's saying well we have uh
centralized information control still
because it's all the [ __ ] big tech
companies
that's gonna change too because silicon
valley can't maintain
dominance forever they're gonna build
another one of those right here in
florida
that's going to be compete with that and
then they'll build another one in texas
and then they'll build another one
anybody can do this this technology is
getting cheap
and if you don't like what you hear here
in the united states you can actually
get involved with [ __ ] like russian
internet or european
internet well you can already do that
now with vpns
just with vpns and [ __ ] so it's just
the big problem right now are smart tvs
these smart tvs are coming
pre-loaded with [ __ ] software that
forces you
channels you right into silicon valley's
[ __ ] like youtube
but there's new stuff coming i think
later on this year
uh there's gonna be a kind of like
silicon valley competitors opening up
right here in florida
that's what the word is and it's both
and
rumored that elon musk is behind it
we'll see
yeah you know yeah because it takes it
takes a lot of money
but now's the time to get in here uh
silicon valley and google and everything
they only had
monopoly because they were first and had
government backing early
they did a lot of good [ __ ] but that
technology can be ripped off even
instantly
and be replicated the the era of the
[ __ ] big tech giant is
rapidly coming to the end they won't be
able to
you know they can't maintain dominance
or supremacy in
an era where everyone can do anything
you know you can just yeah i can do that
too
could be a lot of problems man when
people have [ __ ] the star trek
replicator in their house
yeah we might all be out unemployed and
broke but it won't matter when you can
just make anything you want right in
your house
yeah you don't need money you don't need
money give me some stakes
and it makes sense give me a bar of gold
thank you okay uh you know what give me
give me a bar of [ __ ] thousand dollar
bills give me a whole lot of thousand
dollars that's what i'm saying why would
you need money when you have a
replicator because you could just make
money yeah so
money wouldn't be worth anything i've
seen some [ __ ]
[Laughter]
event horizon really good channel that
talks about stuff like this and these
scientists come on there avi loeb comes
on there
in the economy as we know it is very
[ __ ]
scammy real scammy
we're endless money money out of nowhere
well [ __ ] man
africa does that all the time their
money isn't worth anything why is it why
is our money
worth something it's kind of like a con
game you know it doesn't really mean
anything
eventually this economy is going to be
kind of like
how does this work they don't know how
this [ __ ] works i don't think
we'll see eventually the economy will
technology will make this economy
irrelevant and then
how will the rich people maintain their
income status and scams
it's going to be difficult for them
everything's becoming democratized
everything's becoming a [ __ ] network
we're going to be like the borg
everyone will be about the same
well you know i don't know i don't have
a problem with that no you work from
your house and you just get what you
want you survive you build things that's
what i need to use yeah that's all i
ever wanted to do yeah just everybody
leave me the [ __ ] alone and let me do
what it let me make my [ __ ]
yeah and let me not and let me have
enough food to eat and not starve to
death and here's the weirdest thing
decentralized governments like in
washington dc were
from another technological era where you
needed for technological reasons
centralized control and command
now with internet inter internet
connectivity
you don't even really need these
governments in the same way that you did
so all this shit's gonna have to be
redefined in a way that people will
enjoy it and
we can reap the benefits of it and that
you can have human rights
and be free and you can't you know
stepping on other people's dicks
you know what i mean that let's get back
to the probe through i'm i'm
pontificating
yeah i started yeah i know okay
all right go ahead like i said i'm
trying to do the time i'm going to try
to do the show i have a lot of [ __ ] left
yeah and it's like man it's like i'm
going to be [ __ ] so
wasted by the end of this i'm not going
to be able to which is strong
okay i got water too i got it i have a
glass
yeah it's delicious it worked well with
that i have a glass of water over here
too so it's like i'm i'm kind of
switching them out yeah in between
connor vasalon is in the house
and tell you about khan khan was [ __ ]
with khan
because kyle showed a picture of him
with his two boys riding behind him
and i'll tell you what he's he's down in
mexico he's got
it looked like a photograph of young tom
cruise and young christian slater
being driven around by [ __ ] nicholas
cage that's exactly what that looked
like
it's the [ __ ] is the mexican tom cruise
the mexican slater and the mexican
cage all just driving around what it
looked like
you have some good looking boys do i
have a show to you
i think you did yeah it's about miles
yeah yeah yeah i'll show you
tom tomtificating there's another
t-shirt right there yeah top typically
that actually that should be a bumper
sticker yeah it should be
with your little face on it going yeah
all right
so tuesday morning april 20th 1999.
now a lot of people have speculated that
they had actually planned the massacre
for april 19th
perhaps because it was the anniversary
of the oklahoma city bombing
in 1993. um no one is entirely sure of
that
but the reason that they put it off till
april 20th was i guess because
they needed some particular ammunition
and they didn't actually get it until
the evening of the 19th so they had to
push it off until the 20th but
i think they did actually plan to do the
19th so tuesday morning april uh
20th so eric and dylan arrive at the
school and they have two big duffel bags
and they put them in the cafeteria these
bags both contained
some of their propane bombs these were
supposed to detonate at 11
17 a.m they wanted them to detonate at
this time in particular because this was
during the first
lunch shift which was the largest uh you
know which would have been the largest
concentration of students in the
cafeteria at that time so they wanted to
cause
the maximum damage obviously spoiler
alert uh these two bombs did not go off
happily
um so no one knows exactly when they put
the duffel bags there though uh it seems
like they were already there
like when because i guess like the kids
would come in and like put all their
backpacks and [ __ ] in there
some people said maybe there was like an
after prom party like a week before
maybe they put them in there then and
nobody had noticed them so it's like but
they were in there
like later on now there was this dude um
who was a sheriff's depart deputy neil
gardner he was uh
you know he was kind of their what do
you call it their uh school resource
officer now normally he uh would be
eating his lunch in the cafeteria with
the students
but on this particular day he was
actually um eating in his
patrol car and he was kind of like
watching the students that were out
smoking by the
you know but field by the school or
whatever um now
at this point too but i guess before
dylan and eric got to school
they also had two backpacks that were
filled with pipe bombs
um a bunch of their aerosol canisters
and a couple of
littler propane bombs and they kind of
put those in a field
about three miles away from the high
school and as i said earlier these were
like diversionary bombs they kind of
thought oh these are gonna go off
all the cops and the firefighters will
go there and then we'll be able to like
cause
maximum damage at the high school like
and there won't be like authorities to
show up
you know before we can get all our [ __ ]
done you know what i'm saying yeah
um however uh as we mentioned earlier a
lot of their pipe bombs and [ __ ] did not
go
off um the pipe bombs did go off and one
of the aerosol canisters went off
um but it just caused like a little
bitty fire firefighters came over
like put it out with a hose and
everything was fine um
the bomb guys came over there and
uh kind of called the cops and were like
yeah these might have motion activators
on them it's like they went off but it
wasn't
any maximum damage or anything so but
they kind of did like warn about it
they didn't really have any idea what
was happening with school because
nothing had happened at the school yet
uh 11 10 a.m uh eric and dylan both
arrive
separately at the high school columbine
high school
eric parked in the junior student
parking lot they were both seniors by
the way in case i didn't
did not mention that dylan uh which if
you're not from here that's
your final year of high school when
you're 17 or 18 years old here before
you graduate
so dylan parked in the senior student
parking lot now
they were planning as i mentioned
earlier where they had planted most of
their bombs was in the cafeteria because
they thought that that would cause the
maximum damage
um so the reason that they kind of
parked the or that he parked in that
particular parking lot was because that
was like the nearest the cafeteria he
could get in and out of it without being
seen too much
so the uh his car and
eric's car and dylan's car both also
contained bombs
they were supposed to go off at noon now
eric harris pulls into the parking lot
and runs into brooks brown
now as i said these had been friendmies
i guess
um he had basically in some of his blog
posts earlier like from a year or two
earlier he had said he wanted to kill
this person
because of some slight that i can't
remember what it was it was something
like [ __ ]
stupid and lame but that teenagers would
care about
but by this point they had patched
everything up
so brooks brown was out smoking a
cigarette
and eric says um
hey i like you now so get out of here
go home so they told them to go home
um and they were kind of like okay and
they did i mean
happily so they're kind of like all
right that's a little weird so they did
they took off and they went home
now at this point in the parking lot
eric harris and dylan klebold
they basically they had they put their
trench coats on which were actually
dusters
uh you know put all their backpacks on
put all their guns on and whatnot
um now later on
i think that the reason why marilyn
manson and kmf dm and [ __ ] like that got
so much [ __ ] in the
you know aftermath of this [ __ ]
tragedy
was because it was erroneously reported
that they had marilyn manson t-shirts on
during the rampage that was not the case
um eric harris actually had a t-shirt
that said natural selection on it which
yeah it happened okay that's why he's
not around anymore
yeah you got your ass got wiped out
douchebag yeah that's like a darwin
award right now yeah darwin awards too
bad you had to take so many innocent
people down with you but whatever [ __ ]
they were confused young men
you know i don't know a lot of people
are confused when they're young
it's just that doesn't excuse it i'm
sorry that doesn't excuse it get your
[ __ ] [ __ ] together people seriously
look at it like a natural disaster kind
of like these women that go through uh
postpartum depression they go and drown
all their babies in the damn
bathtub it's like that
dude's going it's like puberty yeah
they're about dumb as rocks
but they're you know no experience they
have enough iq to get themselves in
[ __ ] trouble
uh but not enough to [ __ ] not know
how to do this kind of [ __ ]
and then uh they uh get involved they
[ __ ]
um put them on they're probably on some
of those [ __ ]
what they call those there's a [ __ ]
ssri
inhibitors yeah and probably on that
which [ __ ] cuts down your ability to
feel empathy for other people
uh and emotion and [ __ ] they go and
do this [ __ ] you know that's i think
that's what i think it was and all that
[ __ ] testosterone
and being dumb yeah yeah testosterone
and being dumb that is
that is a very dangerous comment yeah
testosterone is a dangerous point it is
honestly while i was researching this
show and i was like because like i said
you know we were both i was well out of
high school and well out of college when
this happened
but it was in the media because you know
we were goths and stuff we got like [ __ ]
on a lot
because of this like you know it was a
whole new
wave of getting [ __ ] on yeah because of
what these [ __ ] did
um so i can't so i remember that but
it's kind of like
i don't know man it's just this thing
where
where the [ __ ] was i even going with
that what did i say what did i say it's
just a testosterone
yeah yeah so i was thinking about this
and i was thinking to myself
do you okay is it unreasonable to think
that maybe
maybe we should keep teenage boys in
cages
until they're old enough to like behave
like humans is that you know and then i
was like is that bad then i thought that
you're behaving like humans you're very
human it's just uh
you know humans are primitive they need
to be in a high
a lot of teenage boys especially if
they're ramped up in their [ __ ] high
test
i test they're not all the same uh but
if they're
they you could do a blood test the ones
that are very high testosterone
need to be kept physically active you
got to get them [ __ ] tired first
thing you do in a day
first thing you do in the morning is you
run them run them or you [ __ ] have
them out there
it's just like it's just like when you
have a cat
and you don't want them keeping you
awake at night you have to like
you have to play with them with the tool
with the little you know thing on the
string
and you have to just like do that until
they're like super tired because
otherwise they're going to be like
yes they're going to be all climbing all
you have to do the same with teenage
boys you dangle some [ __ ] in front of
their face
yeah and get them to run after it yeah
competitive sports and you [ __ ] you
know what i mean
you don't put them in a classroom that's
the last thing you do with them
that's you don't do that with them you
know uh because that'll just drive them
[ __ ] crazy if you get their zoomies
out
yeah it has to be kind of hands-on
teaching at that age
the [ __ ] test the testosterone level
is too high
what you do is you teach them how to
pull a car engine and how to rebuild an
engine and to show them how all this
[ __ ] works
how to [ __ ] fight teach them how to
fight all right that way
they don't [ __ ] kill people by
accident well like you said get them get
them like
into [ __ ] sports or or just sell or
building things
doing something making [ __ ] yeah it's i
feel like dudes have to always be
constantly occupied
otherwise they're going to cause trouble
then you teach them history in a certain
way that [ __ ]
that you teach them history from a
certain advantage point
that boys would like it you know i mean
there's a boy way of telling history
show them spartacus
just yeah the age of empire
and [ __ ] on the high seas and
you know and
[ __ ] going to the [ __ ] moon
and you know and it's everything
is is has to be badass everything has to
be badass
and then you don't [ __ ] you don't
worry about math that much
you know just very basic you know
[ __ ] some
mathematics you know like uh addition
subtraction
multiplication division maybe some
fractions you know
i mean you have to teach them some [ __ ]
or they'll just be more on yeah
very big no save that you save them
the more the higher end stuff for later
until they've settled down once that
[ __ ] testosterone has [ __ ] kind of
trailed off on them a little bit
you don't [ __ ] try to make these
[ __ ] scholars no
you make them explorers well i mean it
depends on the person
i mean it depends on the person if you
get a lot of like
kids that are troublemakers i think it
probably is better to yeah
you do you gotta do a blood put them in
that and see exactly
you turn them into workers explorers
soldiers something that they would like
to do they don't want to be [ __ ]
scholars
talking about it's for [ __ ] nerds
nerds that's not what they're that's not
what they're for
build [ __ ] with those dudes or you break
[ __ ] with them you know
go [ __ ] tear that [ __ ] down so we'll
go pull something in its way
you know go go fight those dudes over
there man they're a problem okay
all right or you could just like teach
them boxing or fencing
they're not kids you know what i mean
they're between [ __ ] 18 and 24 and
you're out there look man i want you to
go burn down that country
burn down that whole [ __ ] country and
then when when it's done you come back
and then we're going to put colonies
over there
you can have some that land that's how
it was done in the ancient times that
it works and it works now if you see any
cute girls over there bring them too
okay what if the cute girls don't want
to come it don't matter you trade them
up
it never matters it didn't matter you
hear that cute girl
it doesn't matter because why what you
want this is ancient [ __ ] man it's like
[ __ ] conan
those [ __ ] the men were all dead
that's why they got you they they
defeated your men
they defeated your man so what if we
what if we would prefer to just live
like without the men
can we just go over here and be by
ourselves with the cats
you can be lesbian and [ __ ] have a
man i didn't no i didn't even say we
don't need we don't need to be lesbian
we just want to be alone we just want to
be alone you can be alone just leave me
alone with a cat so i can read
you know what i mean it doesn't work
that way it doesn't work it doesn't work
that way in the [ __ ]
ass 17 year old boy it doesn't work that
way i i don't i don't get any choices
okay this is theory this is all this is
all theoretical
this is all theoretical
theory listen to what this [ __ ] is doing
to you what's that
it's making you all greasy and smelly
you guys don't know so many people may
not know what's going on
and it's making you think that you're
going back to like ancient rome yeah
and you can just go and like kidnap a
bunch of whole country full of women
that's okay [ __ ] it with me is because
like
past two days my [ __ ] trt is kicking
in like [ __ ] crazy i [ __ ] feel
like a
walking [ __ ] grease ball i'm just
[ __ ] sweating
grease it smells like [ __ ] pork
grease yeah just like my brothers when
they were kidnapped
i remember that oh man you walk into
their room and you're like oh yeah
oh yeah i'm getting [ __ ] bruises
bruises just from [ __ ] swelling up
and [ __ ]
and and um sleeping coming out coming
out of that sickness
and it's just looking they told me when
it would hit me it's just hitting me
it's hitting me yeah it makes you
[ __ ] crazy hormones are hell of a
drug
they are yeah yeah i mean you know but
no i understand exactly why they did it
i understood it back then serpent surfer
said welcome to the tom ross curriculum
burning down countries
and taking sex slaves
it makes hormonal sense that's why it
went down that way
so i'm watching [ __ ] spartacus now
why were we watching the whole sparta
because
it's better now i'm like well yeah
that's right
so many boobies well now that boobies
then like got each other's heads off
cutting each other's heads and arms off
yeah
yeah oh he deserved that [ __ ] well i
like all the blood too and honestly i
like all the [ __ ] palace and trick of
like what
especially that one character then what
[ __ ] her name that um
that one like [ __ ] you know what i mean
yeah it looked like a blonde
yeah oh my god everything's [ __ ]
worse yeah
oh my god a woman of your age should
have you know just all of me everything
she says is like passive aggressive like
[ __ ] catty [ __ ] like everything is
shade and it's like i kind of love it
like i love the interaction between like
everyone is so so [ __ ] on the show
like the men the women everybody's
[ __ ] tina's [ __ ] said pork grease
yeah i do i feel like i'm [ __ ] just
sweating out damn
raw bacon grease yeah oh
like last time we were watching
spartacus and he was like look touch my
back i'm like no
well sweet we were like what the hell is
going on
[ __ ] running hard as a dog man
[ __ ] really hot
and sweating [ __ ] pork grease i
[ __ ] my
my waist reduced by two inches in
[ __ ]
three weeks just getting that v taper
coming in
just [ __ ] tearing me up like i said
he's going to be rampaging he's going to
be bouncing all over this little frame
right here just like
yeah hulking out they put me on [ __ ]
mood stabilizers
probably we'll see how that goes week
six
it [ __ ] evens out and then it stays
like that
and uh all the da they say that you
adapt to it
just i haven't felt this way in a long
time yeah yeah feels good
well let's see how it feels good yeah
i'm just going to stay over here feels
good yeah
so how did we get up on that thing oh
simply because i mentioned
that uh eric harris had a shirt that
said natural selection on yeah yeah you
just went off on this big tear
uh so yeah so they didn't have marilyn
manson shirts on
eric harris has said natural selection
dylan's
said wrath yeah like i said
nicole says edge and the lords yeah
yeah so as i said thankfully the bombs
they played in the cafeteria failed to
detonate now so what ends up happening i
guess because the bombs didn't go off
when they were supposed to
so i guess maybe allegedly they went to
plan b
which was just we're just gonna shoot
everybody because like i said their
original plan was they're gonna set the
bombs off
and then all of the people that ran out
of the school or got away from the bombs
they were gonna shoot them as they were
running out but that's obviously not
what happened
11 19 am there's a girl named rachel
scott she was 17
and her friend richard costaldo and they
were having lunch
on the grass next to the west entrance
of the school
dylan throws a pipe bomb toward the
parking lot
uh it partially detonated just like
smoke came out but it didn't like blow
up it didn't hurt anybody
um so at this point everybody's thinking
no one is thinking that this is like
anything bad everybody just thinks it's
kind of like a prank and as i said
earlier
these two had made like a fake
commercial called hitmen for hire where
they basically walked around the walls
of this they're the halls of the school
like shooting at people with fake guns
wearing trench coats so everybody just
thought they were doing more of that
i guess so um
yeah so basically at this stage
after this one bomb was thrown that sort
of went off
somebody said at this point one of the
boys they don't know which one
yelled go go and then dylan
uh and eric both pulled their guns from
under the trench coats and started
shooting at everybody rachel scott
was the first one to be killed she was
17 years old as i said
she was hit four times with rounds fired
from harris's uh eric harris's carbine
uh she got shot the shot that killed her
i believe was to the left side of her
temple amazingly uh richard costaldo was
shot
eight times in the abdomen the arm and
the chest
uh he lived but he was paralyzed uh
below the chest so he's paralyzed from
here down
from uh you know to this day now at this
stage
uh eric is he aims his carbine down the
west
staircase uh there are three students
down there daniel
rorbow sean graves and lance kirkland
um as i said everyone just thought this
was a prank at this stage they thought
they were paintball guns
they were actually going to walk up the
staircase
but eric fired at them daniel rorbow was
killed immediately
graves and kirkland were injured now at
this stage there was a teacher
and a coach named dave sanders he was in
the cafeteria and he heard gunfire and
started telling the kids in the
cafeteria hey something bad is
happening maybe we should like [ __ ]
hide or run out of here whatever
now at this point both boys turned
started firing west in the direction of
five students
who were sitting on the hillside next to
the steps
opposite the west entrance of the school
one of these was michael johnson
um he was shot in the face the leg and
the arm
but he ran uh managed to run away and he
escaped
mark taylor uh he got shot in the chest
the arms and the leg
uh he fell and then at that point uh
faked death
so he actually um you know didn't die
but he
was injured obviously uh the other three
got away
uh without being shot at this point
dylan uh walks down the steps towards
the cafeteria he came up to lance
kirkland
uh who was already who had already been
shot once he wasn't dead but he was
wounded
and he was uh laying there like kind of
calling for help
very weakly at this point dylan says
sure i'll help you
and then shot him in the [ __ ] face
amazingly again he survived
this injury even though he was shot
right in the face
now at this point graves who was uh
paralyzed beneath the waist like i said
had actually crawled
to the doorway of the cafeteria's west
entrance and he had collapsed
he also played dead he had the presence
of mind to like rub some blood on his
face so it looked like he was dead so he
just kind of laid there and
you know really still so he didn't get
shot again
um then dylan walks towards the
cafeteria door
he steps over graves is what he thought
was his dead body
and graves later reported that dylan
said to him
sorry dude like thinking that he was
dead
now dylan goes into the cafeteria
um there were a bunch of people still in
there but he didn't shoot at any of them
um they think that maybe he went on
there to check and see
um why the propane bombs hadn't gone off
or
you know checking on them to see if they
would go off um eric was still at the
top of the stairs and he was still
shooting at people at this stage
um uh he shot a 17 year old girl named
anne-marie hockhalter
she was partially paralyzed from the
injuries
at this stage dylan comes out of the
cafeteria and goes back up to the stairs
where eric harris was
and then they started shooting at
students outside that were standing
close to the soccer field they didn't
hit anybody
then they started going toward the west
entrance they were throwing pipe bombs
uh as they were going in a whole bunch
of directions at once they threw a few
on the roof
um thankfully not many of these went off
um you know and no one was injured from
them
um at around this point in the rampage
several witnesses said they heard one of
the boys they weren't sure which one
say and i quote this is what we always
wanted to do
this is awesome so
[ __ ] these two pretty much so at this
point
there's a teacher named patty nielsen
she was an art teacher
um she at first like a lot of people did
you know and like i said it's it's easy
to say in hindsight
that you know nobody knew it was like
you know
everyone was real slow to figure out
what's going on but you wouldn't this
wasn't a common occurrence in 1999 so
no one would have immediately kind of
twigged to what was going on
so everybody just thought it was kind of
like a joke or like people were throwing
fireworks around or whatever
and it's kind of a big school so they
wouldn't have you know seen everything
that was happening
so patty nielsen the art teacher um
she started walking toward she like
heard a lot of noise and
didn't know what was going on so her and
this other this student named brian
anderson
they walked toward the west entrance and
again she kind of just thought it was a
prank and she was gonna go tell whoever
was doing it to like
knock it off and so
brian anderson opens the double doors
and at this stage the shooters shot out
the windows and he got injured with the
glass like flying
back in there um patty nielsen got hit
in the shoulder with
shrapnel so both of them like ran back
down to the library
and uh patty nielsen at this point told
the kids that we're in the library hey
like somebody's shooting
like something bad is happening
everybody get under the desk everybody
hide and shut up
so and she started uh she dialed 9-1-1
at this stage and hid under the
uh counter in the library uh brian
was uh injured but would
survive he actually hid in another room
in the library
now at this point it's 11 22 a.m so
there's a custodian
he calls the uh school resource officer
neil gardner and he called him on the
radio
and he said uh hey i need some
assistance in the senior parking lot
um he had heard that there was
the only report that they had was a
female is down
at this point they thought that she had
been hit by a car
um but a couple minutes later it kind of
became clear what was going on so there
was another call that came over the
school radio that said hey there's a
shooter in the school so they had to
kind of like get their [ __ ] together
now and like i said at this point this
was 1999 this was not a common
occurrence
so they didn't really have a lot of
protocol in place for how to deal with
this kind of [ __ ]
because like i said in the aftermath i
feel like a lot of people
kind of got on the authorities for their
slow
response but
as i said a lot of people thought it was
a joke at first nobody really knew what
was going on
and so the response to it was a little
bit
scatter shot i guess you know if you if
you want to say it like that
so eric is at the west entrance at this
point he
uh he turned around and he fired ten
shots from his carbine
at uh the school resource officer the
deputy uh
neil gardner he was about 60 yards away
now at this point eric had to reload
so gardner basically he
leans over the top of his car he fires
four rounds at eric from his service
pistol
uh but eric ducked back behind the
building
now him ducking back behind the building
it was like really quick and he for a
second he thought he had hit him
um but he didn't but so then eric came
back out and fired uh four more rounds
at gardner
uh but missed and just ended up hitting
a couple of cars in the parking lot
and then went back into the building so
no one got hit during this particular
fire fight
so at this stage the deputy officer says
um
you know there's shooters in the
building somebody needs to come over
here and like
help me out at this stage in the attack
eric harris had shot 47 times dylan
klebold only
five times and like i said you'll see
that
eric harris a lot more ammunition
during the attack than dylan did and
somebody pointed out earlier and i think
i kind of agree with this that if
dylan klebold had never met eric harris
i don't think dylan would have done this
on his own would eric harris have done
this on his own
probably um but it was just
a case of two guys that should not have
been hanging out together
hanging out together we've had that when
we did you know because we've done a
couple of shows about like killer
couples
and we kind of energy yeah we kind of
talk about that a lot where sometimes
like you know the person by themselves
might be okay but then they meet that
wrong person
that and there's just the circumstances
are exactly
perfect you know in a way that
ends up causing disaster for everybody
just as
granthar's there in the damn comment
section he went to high school with me
that's the way me and steve were we were
exactly like that except it was about
women
because the synergy was about those
girls man
we were doing [ __ ] we wouldn't have done
it if the other one there
well and particularly when you're
younger because when you know when
your peer group means so much to you and
you haven't really established an
identity of your own i guess yeah yeah i
had it
for my own well i mean you're still kind
of like working that out trying to outdo
each other and [ __ ] and you know what
i mean and there's something about
when you got another dude who you
[ __ ]
just respect you know what i mean he's
like your brother right and
it goes the other way he's talking you
up he'll [ __ ] caught he'll he'll get
your head
as big as a [ __ ] 55 gallon oil drop
all right
and then you'll do the same thing to him
and then next thing you know
you guys just think you can do anything
and what's funny is a lot of times you
can
confidence [ __ ] goes a long ways
confidence goes all very long ways
it does yeah but like i said there's a
dark side to that too
and we've talked about that in a lot of
our killer couple shows and that i think
that was definitely the case
in here i think eric harris was probably
just a psychopath
but i do think dylan might have grown up
okay
um if he hadn't hung out with eric
harris all the time because i just feel
like this was just like a terrible
well i could see i could see how you
know what i mean that kind of synergy
could go either way it could it could go
down a [ __ ] bad path or it could go
down a good path
you know with with me and steve it was
it was a good path it was fun
you know what i mean we weren't killing
people well obviously
we're not stealing [ __ ] you know what i
mean like that you know just
so but i could i understand i understand
the synergy
what they're talking about yeah well
like i said that's you know
people have synergy like that and it's
usually a good thing but
not always not in this case so
uh at this stage they're going through
uh they go back to into the school
through the west entrance
they're kind of going through the north
hallway they're just throwing pipe bombs
the whole time because like i said they
had built like a whole bunch of them
and they were just anyone they saw they
were just shooting at them
so there was a girl named stephanie
munson um they shot at her
it hit her in the ankle but she was
actually able to escape
she ran out of school um then the two of
them shot out the windows on the east
entrance
then they went through the hall a bunch
of times and shooting uh
at pretty much any students they saw
happily they missed all
of them and then they went into the
hallway where the
door to the library was now at this
point
two more cops arrived they were uh paul
smoker and paul
magor magor maegor i'm not sure if i'm
pronouncing that right
they were both what
michael sheamus and tom did steve go on
tour with you with the go-go's
said yeah yeah he did he did steve me
and steve both went on tour with the
girl girls
you guys i got this [ __ ] thing where
when never mind
i should i took okay jenny made up a
[ __ ] bunch of [ __ ] pictures of me
with all these [ __ ] famous people i
just made up a bunch of stories i posted
them up on facebook one time
they looked real as [ __ ] one of them was
me on tour with the go-go's
what else do we mean just all kinds of
[ __ ] anyway it doesn't matter gotta go
backstreet but that's
freddie mercury david baby hanging out
with freddie mercury andrew
andrew eldridge that's right yeah that's
[ __ ] funny oh
me as a little child in my [ __ ] stp
[ __ ] monkey suit uh
uh telling [ __ ] uh even knievel how
to do the snake canyon jump
standing right it looked real [ __ ] like
i was trying to explain to him it
doesn't look good
yeah yeah um all right so at this point
like uh the first two deputies arrive
um you know they were on motorcycles at
first but they kind of like met up some
some other ones and kind of got the
scoop on what was going on so they get
in the car with these other patrolmen
that were arriving so
they all kind of get there now uh at
this stage
uh there was another gun fight uh this
broke out at 11 26 a.m
eric harris was uh returning to the
double doors and started shooting at
deputy gardner who was the school
resource officer again
and he also returned fire no one was hit
during this exchange
now inside the cafeteria um there were
several people like a couple of
custodians and one of the teachers
basically told the students hey get
under the tables um but then at this
point they were just kind of like all
right we're gonna get you the [ __ ] out
of here so they
um took the all the kids up to like the
stairs and they took them up to the
second floor
and then they took them um to the main
south hallway and then tried to
kind of like close them in like as well
as they could
at this point uh eric and dylan are
inside the main hallway
um brian sanders and another student
uh were at the end of the hallway and
then he kind of gestured to the people
in the library to stay in there
and at this point like dylan and eric
kind of came around the corner like to
where the library was
and then so they turned and ran away
obviously
um and eric and uh dylan shot at both of
them
now so so one of them ends up getting
hit twice he got shot in the neck in the
back
um and it took his teeth out like the
bullet took his teeth out when it was
coming out but missed the other one
um the other one like ran to another
classroom told everybody to hide
you know um so they're still like
they're shooting at everybody they're
throwing pipe bombs whatever so at this
point sanders
is going towards the science teacher
they go or the science uh
area where the classroom was so he goes
to this classroom there's 30 students in
there
and um so so at this point like i said
it's chaos everybody kind of knows
what's going on
they're all in this classroom they're
hiding under the [ __ ]
tables or whatever um now one of the
students
aaron hansey who uh knew a lot about
first aid
so he gets brought into this classroom
from one of the teachers because you
know one of the
other students is wounded so uh him and
this other
uh student named kevin starkey and there
was another teacher named theresa miller
they actually uh administered first aid
to sanders for three hours
they were kind of trying to uh stem the
blood loss
obviously um using you know people's
shirts and [ __ ] like that
and they were trying to keep him from
falling asleep so they kept showing him
pictures of his family like from his
wallet or whatever just to keep him from
uh you know from falling asleep so he
wouldn't die which
is really [ __ ] scary when you think
about it three hours
you guys they were in this classroom and
they were trying to keep this dude alive
so as i said so the two guys are going
down these halls like throwing [ __ ]
pipe bombs
um down the hallways down in the
cafeteria
um you know the art teacher patti
nielsen she's still on the phone with
9-1-1
she's telling all the kids in the
cafeteria or the in the library rather
to take
cover beneath the desks this was 11 25
a.m 11 29 a.m four minutes later
uh eric and dylan enter the library
at this point there are two librarians
and two teachers and 52 students
inside the library eric fires his
shotgun twice
at a desk um there was a student named
evan todd
who had been standing near a pillar when
the shooters entered the library he just
gone behind like a copier
and he ended up getting hit by wood
splinters in the eye in the lower back
but was not seriously injured and then
he ran around and hid behind another
desk
so the shooters walk into the library
towards where the computers were
now sitting in one of the
i don't know if he was sitting like on
one of the rows where the computers were
like sitting in front of one of the
computers
there was a student named kyle velasquez
who was disabled
um and dylan basically just like
shot him in the head with his shotgun
like the kid was just sitting there
um again this this particular crime
i'm not saying that like everything
before this was great or anything but
the fact that they just killed kids they
didn't even know
or kids that were just kind of like like
i said this was just like a little
disabled kid
nobody they didn't even know him so the
narrative
that kind of got you know bandied about
about this that it's like it was revenge
for all these people that bullied them
i think to a large extent that was
something that
they used as justification and something
that kind of got blown up in the media
afterward because
they were just killing everybody they
didn't give a [ __ ] they were killing
people they didn't even know
they were killing people that had never
done anything to them they were just
you know running around causing mayhem
yeah that's that's all they wanted to do
i feel like they just wanted to feel
powerful yeah um they felt like
they were smarter than everybody they
were cooler than everybody they couldn't
understand why girls didn't fall at
their feet
uh you know a couple of them you know
they wrote that kind of [ __ ]
and their thing it's like what why don't
people invite me to things why don't
girls like me
if they were like it was very kind of
in-cell some of their stuff yeah what's
funny thing is though is that after all
the shooting went down i remember that
there was some of the
some girls that kind of hung out in
their little circle
the one they didn't they're the one they
weren't ones that had anything to do
with it but they just knew them
so that there were girls that liked them
there were yeah
well they had dates for things yeah they
were they weren't like they weren't
losers or anything no
you know even if they were that wouldn't
justify it but i'm just saying that they
weren't
i think it was in their mind it wasn't
good enough
that's what i'm saying they wanted to
sell that narrative that they were
victims
somehow i think another thing i think
they believed it i think they
believed that they were yeah they did
but they just didn't realize how good
they had it
another thing is is that um based on
what i remember that girl saying they
had girls that liked them but they
didn't pursue those girls
they probably didn't probably didn't
recognize it isn't that the case
yeah with a lot of dudes like this and i
feel like this happens with a lot of
these kind of in-cell style
shootings and all this because there's
been a lot of them subsequently and a
lot of them
kind of idolize dylan and eric
for this very reason because a lot of
these outcasts they got back at him you
know they got back at everybody that
picked on him and did it yeah and i
think a lot of it was largely
self-invented i mean it's like they had
friends they had they did activities
they
you know they they had families that
loved them they weren't from like
[ __ ] dysfunctional families
they had families that had money they
were upper middle class that's what i
mean yeah
and like i said their parents and
everything like that seemed like lovely
people
there there was nothing um in their
upbringing i'm like [ __ ]
do you understand like how shitty like
some people have it
and they turn out just fine you know
what i mean so
it's kind of like the fact that they
were whining
about you know yes maybe they got
bullied
but a lot of people do i got bullied a
lot of people get bullied particularly
in high school
people but bully each other and the
thing
i'm not saying it's good you shouldn't
bully people but i'm just saying that
doesn't justify
it's part of growing up though it is i
mean it doesn't how humans are it
doesn't justify
going and [ __ ] killing people that
had nothing to do with it i think what
it was is that they were sensitive
they had a very high standards
themselves which meant that they had
they really thought highly of themselves
well obviously and when [ __ ]
didn't go eric harris did i think dylan
harris was
self-loathing okay well when things did
really didn't go all that
didn't go perfectly then it wasn't good
enough
and when people said you know [ __ ] to
him sideways then oh my god it's the end
of the world you know
if they got picked on at all man these
people you know we got to do something
with this you know what i mean
it was like that just very reactive
very high well who was that other
[ __ ] that was kind of like that
had the [ __ ] manifesto about how
women wouldn't date him so he had
justified
elliot roger yeah okay
so that dude dude here's the thing
that oh my god that dude don't even get
me started on this [ __ ] because
what is this mentality that these types
of dudes have
that you think it's like oh hey well i'm
good looking and i have an expensive car
and i have this that and the other thing
women should just be like throwing their
[ __ ] at me
and the fact that he never he never felt
the need to
ask girls out he never felt the need to
work on his like personality and be
like he had a prince charming
competition have some like social skills
i think that he thought
like if i'm reasonably good looking and
have money in a nice car
then women should just offer themselves
to him and the fact that they didn't
was very offensive to him yeah yeah well
which that
blows my [ __ ] mind i watched dude's
videos
yeah i did too i was just amazed you
know i was just [ __ ] absolutely
amazed
i got the feeling from watching the
videos
it definitely wasn't something right
with it dude i think it was some kind of
autism
what it seemed like yeah um he was just
looking at things on a very superficial
level
as if everything's like a computer
program or a robot
if you look like this if you do this if
you have this if you do
you know i mean if you're dressed like
this then it automatically happens that
this happens
and this happened yeah that's exactly
why and honestly i've seen
other people make that exact comparison
because they'll say that like women are
not
vending machines yeah that you put
certain coins
and then sex comes out right that is not
how people work
but he works like that right so he
thought everyone else yeah yeah because
yeah i was watching his mannerisms and
everything in his facial expressions
he's very artificial very robotic yeah
which means that there's a lot of weird
things that could happen to the frontal
lobes of a
of a brain it's where you're you know
what i mean where your consciousness
resides yes big time
could be that that there that he wasn't
fully conscious he might have been like
an a
a by a biomechanical artificial
intelligence like an ai robot
he might have been like ai in a way
like he you know he had some kind of a
organic problem in his brain
well very similar to say like anesthesia
you know you can put a person under
anesthesia and they can walk around and
talk and everything when it wears off
they can't remember
they can't remember anything during that
time they weren't conscious you know
they were talking
under the influence she did it when she
was under anesthesia
well they might be basically kind of
like under anesthesia
maybe they're not conscious they're like
a working robot
yeah you know yeah you think i i tick
this box
that box in that box therefore
then this is what i meant when humans
have a problem with complexity that's
not sure works
there's a lot of other factors that have
to be considered well just think if you
lived your whole life like that you're
basically a machine you don't have
consciousness
you'd be very confused because you don't
know what the other humans are doing
because i think you're like me another
problem too that a lot of humans have
is that you tend to universalize your
own experience to everyone else yeah it
projects
they project which like i said that's a
very very dangerous thing to do because
everybody is not
you that's right and here's here's
another thing everybody's not you but
another
usually an aggressor always projects
their motives onto you
so whatever a person is accusing you of
that's what they've done somebody just
accuses you out of the blue
of something a lot of times that's what
they've done yeah
so you know just a good thing to know
the enemy
always projects oh yeah oh
i know yeah
oh yeah many times okay many times
yeah um michael shafer says and yet
jenny likes spock
yeah well that's kind of a different
dynamic though he's got kind of a doctor
and spock wasn't a machine he had
emotions
yeah um they were just so volatile that
he had to
suppress them otherwise he'd be like a
raging batshit crazy person all the time
and the women loved him because they
know that he was holding back all that
sexuality right
it wasn't that he couldn't it wasn't
that he couldn't feel that
those things he could he had to hide
that inner [ __ ]
you know there's nothing alluring about
somebody who can't feel those things
there's nothing alluring about that but
somebody that
you know can feel those things deep down
but it's trying to like keep it under
control
there's something alluring about that um
and somebody said earlier that they
uh you know this whole incel thing is
[ __ ] you know that it's
it's obviously voluntary because they
could get laid if they wanted to
if they actually wanted to work on
themselves instead of blaming everyone
else for why they can't get laid
um you know what i mean uh which yeah i
agree with that too i just i you know i
didn't mean to go off on the whole incel
rant but i did get
from a lot of their journal entries um i
got a lot of the same
vibe from their journal entries
as i got from reading like incel [ __ ]
you know what i mean
because they definitely did have this
thing where they thought they were
entitled to
uh women and they couldn't understand
it's like why you know why don't women
like me why don't women
you know why don't i get invited to
parties why why why
and it's like but without really looking
at themselves and it's like well what
can i do to be
more attractive to women what can i do
to you know nobody wants to like work on
their own [ __ ]
everybody just wants to blame other
people for their problems and i feel
like these two were kind of like
some of the poster boys for that [ __ ]
just like a lot of the in-cell shooters
were just like [ __ ] l.a
in the comments yeah the dude we were
talking about was the guy who did
did the video from his car yeah that
dude was [ __ ] he's a fruit loop
that's right
[ __ ] banana pants crazy that dude was
and it's
like i said it's sad because he was a
totally normal looking dude
um he was good looking enough to he
could he he could get women yeah
and the problem is i said the reason
that you can't get women is because
you're a [ __ ]
freak that's why because you're a
[ __ ] psychopath
he was weird it's because of how you act
it's because of how you act
yeah he doesn't matter what you look
like there was something wrong with him
yeah
and he kind of gave off that vibe that
there was something very wrong
yeah and women can smell that [ __ ] from
a mile away
yeah women can smell desperation women
can smell
psycho from a mile away yeah
so you come off like that women will run
in the other direction and it doesn't
matter if you look like a [ __ ] male
model
if you give off that vibe most women
will run miles away from you
yeah and sorry guys just the mathematics
the numbers
ninety percent of the women are
interested in only ten percent of the
men
well and it's always pretty much been
that way well the thing about it that
there's really not a lot of quality men
out there
no that's what i'm saying of view from
the point of view of a woman they're
never
they're either too old or too young
they're too poor
or they're too uh too boring
or they're too you they're just it's
there's always there's
something that yeah there's always
something wrong with them
yeah but yeah so xanada says yet there's
flocks of women online who love the
columbine shooters see i do not
and i don't understand you know we've
talked about this before like women that
are super into like the
serial killer yeah i kind of feel like
this is
even if they're woman age i feel like
this is a this is a severely
emotionally immature yeah this is
someone
who has issues where
i i feel like with immature women
there's a thing that they really like
these
horrible horrible people because they
think
that they can be the only person to
redeem this monster yeah they all like
that
it's a fantasy that immature women like
the vampire of the sago too
that's yeah what's that guy's name
remember i don't know i don't remember
yeah he thought he was a vampire
he's probably forgotten by now probably
yeah well i don't know
i remember like i was kind of like what
richard chase or that other [ __ ]
teenager oh that guy yeah what the [ __ ]
was that good
i don't know i always forget his name
for some reason yeah probably for the
best
woman i worked with [ __ ] handle this
case for a while yeah i
i kind of feel like that that's a a
mental issue into itself
unto itself because i do feel like in
like if you're very immature like
teenager
girl girl was his name there you go
teenage girls
or a certain segment i'm not going to
say all teenage girls because i don't
really have this but um
some teenage girls have a fantasy
that they are going to be the one to
change this bad boy you know whether
it's a serial killer that's kind of an
extreme
obviously but there's kind of a thing
where it's like oh he's kind of a
you know petty criminal or whatever but
you know his love for me
will make him change his ways that's
like a fantasy that they have they think
because they want to feel like you know
his love for her is so strong that he'll
like change his whole entire
you know he'll turn his life around and
it's like this big
but yeah that's i know but that's like a
pretty common fantasy that like
really like the teenage girls have i
guess or some teenage girls like i said
so uh let's see where was i so as i said
they
they killed this poor disabled kid who
was just sitting there doing nothing
uh shot him in the head with a shotgun
now
uh throughout this massacre in the
library
they told everybody to get up um and
they said yeah the library's gonna blow
up
like we put a bomb in here um and a lot
of the witnesses later
said that they were super like dylan and
eric were super super jacked
they were just kind of like yeah wahoo
were doing this [ __ ] dudes they were
like
super pumped about it which like i said
[ __ ] up and i said earlier i don't
think you were here
but um several witnesses said they were
like this is what we always want to do
this is awesome you know so they were
like having a [ __ ] good time
good for them uh nobody else was but you
know whatever
so they basically they're in the library
and they tell all the jocks or the white
hats
um they want all of them to stand up uh
anybody with a white hat or a sports
emblem on it is dead that was the quote
um so nobody stood up because why would
you
because you're gonna get [ __ ] shot um
now a couple of students in there did
have white hats on so they were kind of
taking them off and like trying to like
hide them or whatever
now at this point there were some
windows shot out in the direction of the
police who had just arrived
outside uh and so the cops started
opening fire uh at the windows and uh
the gunman kind of backed up from the
windows no one was injured during this
uh you know gun fight at this point
dylan takes his trench coat off
and then starts shooting his shotgun at
a table nearby
ending up injuring three students
patrick ireland daniel steepleton and
makai hall
at this stage eric walks down the lower
row of computer desks the shotgun
fires a single shot under the first desk
uh he kind of goes down one knee and
shoots under the table
he hit 14 year old stephen curnow or
cornell
with a mortal wound to the neck he then
moved to the adjacent computer desk
injuring 17 year old casey
oh goodness um rugsegger roy sager
i don't know how to pronounce that i'm
very sorry uh the shot went through her
right shoulder
grazed her neck and severed a major
artery she started gasping in pain
and eric harris said i quote quit your
bitching
damn like i said [ __ ] these two
seriously even if somebody did bully
them good they probably deserved it
but like i said i kind of feel like the
whole bullying thing was
overblown and from what i've heard and
from what i've read
it seems like they were doing as much
bullying of others
as maybe people were doing to them so
it's not like they were just like oh
these little
victims or whatever so it's not anything
like that these two are like [ __ ]
psychos
so at this stage uh eric walks to
another table
uh and there were two students
underneath and this is where i want to
get into the whole evangelical
legend thing that happened because this
at this stage
thank you mango thank you very much
raising another pint of cider to the
chat you guys all rock great stream
about a dark day in history thank you
very very very much
i know everybody in the [ __ ]
everybody in the comments section it's
so fun hanging out with you guys
so everybody's in there everybody's
funny they're all [ __ ]
drunk talking [ __ ] which is good because
it's like i i feel like
it's going if i mess up then like
this until they watch it later and then
they're saying this [ __ ] trt you're
gonna be taming the wild beast jenny
i'm still in and then they're going on
[ __ ] beauty to be
yeah [ __ ] trt's got me but i'm in
that [ __ ]
unstable kind of period right now right
it's weird it's bouncing all over the
place yeah pretty much
all the time he's like i feel weird huh
yeah
and i'm like come here and she's like
what yeah and what she's like
okay okay go
and then i'll see something he doesn't
know what the [ __ ] he's going to see
something on tv
i'm going to kill that but oh i said i
took it oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
you know it's weird it's weird do you
know i don't know if you were awake this
morning because i woke up i woke up at
like six and then i was kind of like
[ __ ] man the [ __ ] sun's out i got to
get up soon [ __ ] this
and so i was just kind of laying there
but i heard you i don't know if you were
awake
or not yeah but you said something like
what did you say
you said something like i'm going to
burn everything in the world
or something like that or something like
that yeah i see all kinds of [ __ ] and
i'm just kind of like
okay i don't know i didn't notice that
the headphones are i think all the
blankets were over your head so yeah
i wake up saying crazy [ __ ] i'll wake
myself up
saying some crazy well sometimes i don't
know if you're awake or asleep because
sometimes you'll just say something like
i'll kill you i'll kill you [ __ ]
and i'm just like what
no i'm sleeping he's sleeping yes he's
talking to some dream person yeah i'm
talking to do something i know
and [ __ ] like that you know and what's
funny is that most of the time it's
it it's funny like what i'm thinking
about is funny at the time yeah
like it's i'm
talking to some dude i grew up with or
something you know what i mean
that's you know it's not but sometimes i
am mad
it's weird it just kind of comes and
goes well like i can't really tell and i
don't know if you're awake or asleep so
all of a sudden i'm just kind of there
half asleep and all of a sudden i hear
i'm going to kill you and i'm just like
what
yeah yeah yeah yeah help you might have
stole something from me
there's a story that goes along with it
okay
it's not just out of the blue dude went
in my [ __ ] foot locker and took some
[ __ ]
okay or he got in the wall locker and
took my [ __ ] dress greens and [ __ ]
you know wipe his ass
why you take my shoelace yeah yeah just
[ __ ] like that you know what i mean
it's it's there's a situation behind
it and i'm only speaking out i'm only
speaking out when that when
tensions run high okay you know
it must be a lot better oh there's a lot
of [ __ ] the [ __ ] my brain's doing
all kinds of crazy [ __ ] all the time i
it's funny because i remember
watching blade runner and [ __ ]
there's a scene where deckard [ __ ]
says i'm gonna kill you to somebody they
made a big deal about it in the [ __ ]
movie i do that [ __ ] [ __ ] every day
every night
he does pretty i'm gonna [ __ ] kill
you i'm gonna set you on fire
[ __ ] like that i say all kinds of ways
yeah like in the middle of the night
like literally i'll wake up like to go
to the bathroom like at four in the
morning
and then i'll get back in bed and then
i'll hear him over there yeah
i woke up i'm gonna cut your head off
yeah
i like that yeah this is what i deal
with yeah it's real private
i'm gonna set your ass on fire
i had a [ __ ] dream i was dragging a
dude from the back before wheeler one
time
yikes yeah he deserved it but i don't
remember what it was he did
well then how can you say you deserve to
because i would have been dragging him
if he didn't deserve it
all right yeah he did something wrong i
was dragging it
on the end of a chain [ __ ] yikes
yeah something was happening it was like
something out of the omega man
okay you know what i mean just like that
i'll give you that
yeah all right can i get back to it
go ahead all right you're the one that
wants to talk about this crazy [ __ ]
i'm so [ __ ] hot right now
i'm sweating out [ __ ] bacon grease
dude i have someone to get there
at least let me get through the timeline
and then we can talk about like some of
the [ __ ] because we kind of covered some
of the [ __ ]
but you know all right so like i said at
this point i kind of want to get into
this particular
uh case because this is something that
unfortunately uh evangelical christians
used as kind of a rallying point later
on which
gets kind of [ __ ] up but so at this
point like eric goes up to this table
um and he lowers himself under there are
two students under there
cassie bernal and emily wyant
so basically what eric does he slaps the
table
and then kneels down and he says
peekaboo to these two girls out there so
like i said
[ __ ] douchebag right um then he
shoots cassie bernal in the head with a
shotgun kills her immediately
um at this point like eric had the gun
in one hand he shot with one hand so
obviously the weapon like recoiled and
hit him in the face
i don't know if it's broke his nose but
it injured his nose and it's he's it
started bleeding
um now what happened later on
was that cassie bernal her
parents and like her church and
everything like that they kind of
started spreading around
the myth which i guess it's not entirely
their fault at the beginning because
this
was kind of something that was in the
original you know
story but this wasn't actually what
happened
the story went that eric had asked her
do you believe in god
she said yes and then he blasted her in
the face and killed her
that's not what happened what happened
was that he just ducked down
said peek-a-boo and then he just shot
her and she died
now there was some witness uh testimony
saying that the other girl that was
under the table
or another girl that they were shooting
at they asked do you believe in god and
she said yes and he said why
and she said because i was raised that
way
and then he shot her but she didn't die
you know what i mean
so he did it was kind of like
not entirely fictional but it was just
put on something they wanted to make
cassie bernal into a martyr
i guess um because the book that came
out
in the wake of the shooting was called
she said yes implying that
she had been killed because she said
that she believed in god
that's not exactly what happened
um and after the witness reports after
everything was sorted out and after the
true story came out basically the
evangelicals had already kind of hitched
their wagon to this [ __ ]
and you know the the ones that were
perpetrating it were kind of saying
well everybody already believes that
story so [ __ ] it we're just gonna run
with it even though
even after they learned that it wasn't
true thank you xanada thank you
got my stimulus just now so here's your
cut and i want a plisken shirt when you
send them out please okay all right i'll
get you one out i'm going to write that
down
right now is it against it what size is
that what size you want
yeah just let me know what size you want
and i'll get it out
to you i just sent ken some shirts too
because yeah
we got to make some new shirts too i
know i'll get around to it one of these
days
yeah i mean it's xanada's birthday so we
have to like say happy
thanks for our happy birthday happy
birthday we should have got some cake
santa got [ __ ] and blessed [ __ ]
simultaneously he ordered a [ __ ]
556 [ __ ]
dissipator upper and instead of getting
that he got somebody from psa
and instead of getting that he got a
[ __ ] 300 [ __ ] blackout
upper 10.5 inch [ __ ] flat top
and a [ __ ] [ __ ] uh hula sun red
dot on there
it didn't happen to be the [ __ ] solar
powered one
but that's still with [ __ ] bcg do you
guys know what i'm talking about
with bcg for the [ __ ] price of that
[ __ ] dissipator rupper
psa wouldn't take it back they wouldn't
they wouldn't take it back they wanted
him to pay
pay for the shipping but [ __ ] that
was like 600 worth of [ __ ]
so he kept it he kept it all right go
ahead
all right that's code some of y'all knew
who that is
grantham knows what that is okay yeah um
all right at this point like i said
because he had shot the one girl uh
you know and the gun was in one hand it
had uh recoiled into his face
um like i said i don't know if it broke
his nose but it made his nose bleed so
it looked like he had blood all over his
face at this point
uh so he goes under another table
there's a girl named brie
pasquale pasquale under that table
and eric asked her if she wanted to die
she obviously said
uh you know no i'd rather not or you
know was like please don't kill me
uh eric laughed at her and said
everyone's gonna die that's a quote
then dylan said shoot her eric responded
no we're gonna blow up the school anyway
now at this point there was another
student that was um
you know kind of trying to help out one
of the other ones uh whose knee was
wounded
and um the student that was trying to
help like his head that's a large
okay
gotta get in there somehow yeah okay so
um
so the student that was trying to help
the other student like they kind of put
their head above the
table um at this point dylan shot him
again
hitting him twice in the head once in
the foot um
he was actually knocked out but he ended
up surviving
dylan then walks toward another table
where he found 18 year old isaiah
scholes
or shells 16 sixteen-year-old matthew
kechter
and sixteen-year-old craig scott who was
the younger brother of rachel's
uh of rachel scott who was the first uh
person that was killed in the massacre
um they were all hiding underneath the
table dylan calls out to eric
hey i found an n-word
and tried to pull isaiah shells out from
under
the table so you know like i said these
are
lovely lovely people um eric
leaves brie who like i said
asked her if she wanted to die and she
had plead for her life and they didn't
kill her
um so at this point they're taunting
isaiah
making a bunch of racist comments at him
uh
then both the shooters fired under the
table
um eric ended up killing isaiah
uh shot him twice and or shot him once
in the chest rather
dylan shot and killed uh catched her or
kecked
kekter
um apparently this is see this is [ __ ]
up i don't see i don't know why anybody
would feel sorry for these two [ __ ]
because it's [ __ ] like this so isaiah
like i said they shot him in the chest
they killed him and uh even though no
one had shot him in the head
dylan said i didn't know black brains
could fly that far
you know [ __ ] cold blood both
of these do [ __ ] like i said [ __ ]
burning hell i don't even believe in
hell but burning hell both of you
he's being [ __ ] edge lord that's what
i mean it's like what the [ __ ] man just
knock it off
so um at this point eric says who's
ready to die next
several witnesses said then he throws
uh one of his crickets which was one of
the little like cartridges that had
gunpowder in it he throws at this other
table
there's three um other students under
there it exploded in midair but
apparently it didn't uh really hurt
anybody
now at this point eric walks towards the
bookcases between the west and center
section tables uh section tables in the
library
he jumped on one and then um started
shooting at the books which are falling
off
which okay dylan walks over to the east
area the library eric walks from the
bookcase
um they shoot star then they start
shooting it like just random [ __ ] like
display cases
[ __ ] like that they shot toward another
table
at this point they hit another student
17 year old mark kinkin
who uh was injured uh in the head and
the shoulder he lived though
um at this point turned toward the table
to his left
and uh fired again injuring 18 year olds
lisa kreutz lauren townsend and valeen
schner
with the same shotgun blast they were
all under the same table
now at this stage um dylan goes to the
same table
and fired a bunch of shots with his tech
nine uh
killing lauren townsend who had been uh
injured by one of eric's uh
you know by eric shooting now
at this point see this is where the
confusion happened
with the stuff about um you know the
girl
uh that they kind of made into a martyr
later she was already dead at this stage
sadly so at this point they come to
uh velene schner who had been under this
table she was injured she had been shot
already and she was screaming
oh my god she was screaming so at this
point dylan asks her
do you believe in god and she said yes
and then dylan said why and she said
um because i was raised that way at this
point
dylan says god is gay okay
god this is so edge lordy it makes me so
mad edge lordy
edge lordy people make me sound mad he
meant it in the 90s gay
you're still gay that's gay god is good
yeah god teenage boys are the [ __ ]
worst man
it's like oh oh you're so badass
[ __ ] off jesus christ all right so
people like me
just make me so angry yeah yeah but
there's still dudes like this around
nowadays
it's just this kind of like [ __ ] just
makes me so so angry i just
hate people like this so much so
at this point uh eric gets uh to another
table because like i said there was a
lot of students in this library and
they're all like hiding under the tables
right because the teachers told them too
so eric comes along and there's another
table there's two girls hiding
underneath
he goes down and he looks at him and
he's like they're pathetic
so he didn't even shoot at them which
that's [ __ ] up okay so then he goes on
to another table
and then he fires twice injuring two
16-year-olds
nicole nolan and john tomlin uh
tomlin actually tried to get out from
under the table at which point
dylan shot him repeatedly killing him
so then eric walks over to the other
side of the table where uh
townsend was dead behind the table there
was another 16 year old girl named kelly
fleming
uh she sat next to the table rather than
underneath it because there wasn't
enough space
because everyone was trying to like hide
on this one table and there was enough
room for her
eric shot her uh with a shotgun hitting
her in the back and killing her
um he then shot at the table behind
fleming hitting townsend who was already
dead
lauren townsend she had already been
killed uh hit hit croix again and
also wounded another girl 18 year old
gianna park
at this point the shooters moved to the
center of the library where they
reloaded their weapons at a table
now at this point eric pointed his
carbine under table student he was
aiming at and moved out of the way
eric moved his gun back on the student
told him to identify himself
this was john savage who was a friend of
dylan's
apparently now at this point this guy
is like what are you guys doing and then
dylan shrugs and just says killing
people like that
no we're just killing people who cares
well they already had this planned out
in terms of what they were gonna do
after they did yeah
they were gonna kill each other kill
themselves well like i said i think
originally they plan to just like blow
up the school
and run to another country but yeah like
that would work
yes but i do kind of feel like this was
kind of their next best plan and i do
kind of feel like once the bombs didn't
go off they were just kind of like yeah
we're just going to kill everybody and
then kill ourselves
i think they had kind of already come to
that to that point
so uh so yeah he was just like yeah
we're just killing people
so john savage is like so are you gonna
kill me
and um apparently dylan was like what
and he's like no are you gonna kill me
and then dylan said no
run away so john got away
for whatever reason i guess because they
were friends
so at this point uh eric turns around
fires his carbine at the table directly
north of where he had been he had
he hit a 15 year old daniel mauser in
the hand and in the ear
at this point daniel either
shoved a chair at him or grabbed at his
leg or something like that
um and eric shot again at closer range
and hit him in the face which killed him
now at this point both gunmen moved
south started firing randomly
under another table critically injuring
two 17 year olds jennifer doyle and
austin eubanks
also fatally wounded 17 year old corey
deputer
this was 11 35 a.m and he was
the last victim of the uh
of the attacks so at this still at this
point
dylan said well let's i'm just gonna
start knifing people now um
although they never actually did that so
they started going toward the main
counter
uh eric threw a molotov cocktail toward
the uh one into the library but it
didn't
blow up um then they started like moving
to this one area
uh you know where they were kind of like
regrouping dylan pulls a chair out from
the desk then he points his tech nine at
uh
todd who had a white hat on and said are
you a jock
todd said no and dylan said well that's
good we don't like jocks
then he's like i want to see your face
so todd lifts his head up
uh so sort of so his face was kind of
seen but not really
and then um apparently dylan said give
me one reason why i shouldn't kill you
and then todd says i don't want any
trouble and then
dylan apparently said uh you don't even
know what trouble is
and at which point todd is like uh
that's not what i meant i meant i don't
have a problem with you guys
i never will and never did and then at
this point dylan said
to eric i'm gonna let him live but you
can kill him if you want to
um so eric apparently did not want to
kill
him so then they went to the they said
they were going to go to the commons
which was the cafeteria
uh dylan at this point fires a single
shot into an open
open library staff break room and hit a
television
eric is walking away dylan says one more
thing
then picked up the chair beside the
library counter under which patty
nielsen the art teacher was hiding
slammed the chair down on top of the
computer terminal and the library
counter and that was it
so dylan uh and eric are at the library
entrance the two walked out of the
library at 11 36 a.m
um so at this point there are 10 injured
29
uninjured survivors in the library and
they started to evacuate
through the north emergency exit door
and that led to a sidewalk adjacent to
the west entrance
um so here's the thing
so that was kind of like the end of the
[ __ ] so at this point
i think that the two of them had kind of
decided
that you know the cops were there at
this point
they had kind of i don't you know i
don't think they had run out of ammo
but i don't know as i said none of their
bombs had detonated
um so i kind of feel like they were
still trying to
because at this point like after they
shot all the people in the library and
then they went back into
the um the cafeteria and then they're
starting to shoot at the propane tank
bombs like they still wanted them to go
off
you know what i mean so they were like
shooting at them and then like one of
them like there's
because there's a you know security
camera footage
of them going back in the cafeteria and
then like one of them like dylan goes up
to
uh one of the propane bombs and like
examines it like it's just like
why the [ __ ] isn't this going off which
would have been so so funny if it had
been like [ __ ]
if it had pulled a [ __ ] wiley coyote
and just like got off in his face like
right when he was looking at it but it
didn't unfortunately
so um based on what i heard they
kind of decided to call off the attack
and kill themselves
because they became aware of the fact
that the [ __ ] tactical team was in
the damn school
yeah and they knew that they couldn't go
up against those guys those guys those
guys suck it out numbered them and
out armed them they were they had five
five six weapons
[ __ ] they're [ __ ] m16s basically
is what they had
yeah and uh body armor and
shotguns flashbang grenades gas
all right they didn't they wouldn't and
lots of training and teamwork
they wouldn't have they wouldn't have
stood a chance
okay well yeah they're against the tag
team a couple of idiot teenagers
so instead of [ __ ] you know what i
mean
losing all [ __ ] all [ __ ]
shred of [ __ ] a [ __ ] dignity you
know what i mean
they would have lost every shred of
dignity against attack team
so they did as they ran off [ __ ] like
little cowards and [ __ ] exited this
[ __ ] mortal plane
you know they exited the physical world
because they would have been
they would have been [ __ ] tossed
around like [ __ ] [ __ ]
by the [ __ ] tag team they would have
cut them to shreds
although there had there was a lot of
criticism in the aftermath about why the
cops didn't go in earlier
um because it did seem like there were a
few points where
particularly where the shooters were um
kind of you know shooting at the cops
like out the windows where probably they
could have been hit
and taken out and they just didn't do it
and they didn't go in there
um you know like i said hindsight's 20
20. yeah they
could have done things differently sure
civilians jump into this situation
[ __ ] ass first
like they know what the [ __ ] they're
talking about and start armchair
quarterback and about well why didn't
you do it with this but
the [ __ ] cops didn't know what the
[ __ ] was going on in nowhere well for a
long time they did it i didn't know how
many were in there
[ __ ] you know i mean there's a lot of
stuff that they didn't know
you know once they kind of got a mental
kids were jumping out the windows and
they were asking the kids what was
happening and then once they got a
picture
of what was happening and it was nothing
but just two yahoos running around
[ __ ] shooting people you know then
they decided to go in [ __ ]
balls deep on them with the tag team
because just because you hear
shooting that doesn't mean people are
being killed you might have [ __ ] six
dudes in there
[ __ ] shooting into the roof
intimidating people and and trying to
take them hostage
you know you sent attack team in there
without knowing anything they might
start killing hostages
so they didn't know well and like i said
you do have to kind of tread delicately
this is a high school
high school and it's like you're not
entirely sure who the shooters are
where the shooters are it's like you
don't want to kill innocent people
and you know they they got criticized
too like a you know about a lot of the
people that were coming out
and it's like you know we didn't know uh
at the time when people were being
evacuated if the shooters had changed
clothes
and were you know mingling in among the
victims
so it's kind of like we didn't you know
we didn't know who they were we didn't
know what they looked like
so it's easy for one person to make the
decision
then take a course of action in an
emergency it's a lot harder
when it's groups you know what i mean
you got
you got cops and then their tag teams
and their that's might be three or four
different groups
of police right there you got your line
policeman
all right and then you got your tactical
response team and then you got the
[ __ ]
police brass echelons in other words
their chain of command
it take they're all worried about
different things it's going to take them
four or five times longer to come to
some kind of decision
and then once they come to a decision
about what's going to do or what they're
going to do it's going to take more time
to get these groups coordinated to get
it done
it's not the same as one person you know
been there
[ __ ] the army's it's called a
[ __ ] and
the army is even worse than the cops in
some ways
so i understand what it is that's a
smaller unit
always outruns outperforms out decides
out fights a bigger unit always over and
over again
because they don't have to worry about a
chain of command
and if you're on the offensive you're
the terrorist you don't worry about
[ __ ] civilian casualties
you're trying to maximize civilian
casualties
you know so you're at an advantage when
you're doing this
the mentality is very different you know
from uh from a say like a normal system
well yeah because i mean the thing about
it is that
from the standpoint of you know
dylan and eric you know they didn't care
if innocent people got shot the
authorities did care
right yes that's what i'm saying so you
have to be careful
they didn't have to be careful i
understand how civilians think i was a
civilian
too i used to think that [ __ ] the
police
and the army and everything that they'd
protect you
it's not that [ __ ] that if dudes
attacked that they would
win and win the day it's not that
[ __ ] simple they might win the day
but it would take a long time for
instance
if you had a bunch a bunch of terrorists
inside the united states
they would their their [ __ ] objective
would not be to defeat the army or take
over the government that's not what
their objective is their objective is to
kill
as many civilians as possible to create
havoc
and chaos and to frustrate the army
until the army and the government
dissolves or give them what they want
you know man that's very different it's
a very easy job to do
if you're the terrorist you know
i lost it did you lose it did it no it
looks like we're good here
well i lost the army's [ __ ] job would
be very hard they're trying to stop
this damage from happening that's 10
times harder
so i understand why it took time for the
cops to get in there
yeah but you know on the other hand i
can
understand if your kids were in there
yeah you would be really absolutely
want to get in there and save them yeah
exactly what they're dealing with
but like i said they can't just go in
their guns blazing because you might be
killing a bunch of innocent people and
just be
end up being worse than these [ __ ]
two douchebags were
yeah so at this point like i said there
was another uh you know
fire fight with the cops uh you know a
little bit past noon no one was injured
in that exchange
but by uh 1208 pm a little bit after
noon uh both eric harris and dylan
klebold had shot themselves they
had gone back into the library and uh
basically
eric sat down with his back to a
bookshelf fired his shotgun through the
roof of his mouth
dylan went down on his knees and shot
himself in the left temple with his text